and now with more reaction as RNC
chairwoman rana mcdaniel good evening
rana i it's good to have you here and i
don't know if you heard the last few
minutes where we were talking about how
the mainstream media the media on the
left is doing everything they can to
criticize the president and what he's
doing calling him continually calling
him every name in the book while all of
this evidence comes out about the real
collusion between the left the FBI the
DOJ Fuzion GPS Hillary Clinton and the
DNC yeah I mean their playbook is the
same as it was leading up to the 2016
election when they said he couldn't win
they were prognosticating that he had no
chance to an electoral victory and and
we in the heartland I'm from Michigan we
saw something completely different we
saw people we saw a candidate talking
about higher wages and better trade and
in a country that was lifted up for all
people and that's why Donald Trump won
and again the left straight left-wing
mainstream media continues to ignore the
American people and what we're seeing
because of this president unemployment
at a record low wages are up our country
is rising again good keep ignoring the
facts because the American people are
smarter than that we feel it and we're
going to show it in the midterm while
there's no question all the American
people need to do is you know with some
oh s--- of them look at their paychecks
but also the consumer confidence and and
and the GP and GDP and all that but in
in 2018 let's turn right to the midterms
I mean how is it going to play out in
the various parts of the country where
you know with steel Pennsylvania where
the president has just been visiting and
the other states that he intends to
campaign in four candidates over the
next four months well we've had nine
House special elections we've won eight
of those president Trump is our greatest
asset in in the campaign trail he
energizes our base he brings an energy
to our candidates and we need that
because he goes into Michigan and Ohio
and and other states and he says listen
we have to fight for what we've just
gained our country is doing better our
economy is roaring and jobs are coming
back and if we give it to the Democrats
they will double down on obstruct and
resist and mire us down in
investigations and stop this great
comeback
that is helping every single American
you see african-american unemployment at
the lowest level and history Hispanic
unemployment women these are good things
for our country and this is what we have
to fight for
we've won eight out of nine the RNC's on
the ground we're in 28 states we've
trained to 20,000 volunteers we are
ready to defy history in these midterms
you know Ronna as I listened to you you
are one fighter to why I think the
president really picked the right person
for the job that you're in but very
quickly right you know you know and
we've met at speeches that that around
the country I always get from people
what's gonna happen to all this
wrongdoing how come there are no
consequences what do you say to people
who get frustrated watching us talk
about all of the collusion the
conspiracy the Russia hoax yeah I do
hear that a lot one they are not
interested in the Moller investigation
at all so let's put that aside they know
there's no collusion you know we have
something in our constitution called a
right to a speedy trial boy but we have
investigations that can go on forever
and it's just ridiculous and it needs to
end but they do look at what happened
with Hillary Clinton in the DNC funding
this fake dossier and now new
revelations coming forward that Glenn
Simpson was meeting with Bruce or and
his wife worked for fusion GPS I mean
it's just it's ongoing and we can't seem
to get to the bottom of it and there is
a frustration but I say stick with the
president put more Republicans in the
majority that's the only way we're gonna
get this done we need a bigger majority
in the Senate and we need to send a
message to the mainstream media that
we're not listening to them we're
listening to the results that are
happening on the ground every day that
are benefiting the American people
Ronnie McDaniels so good to have you on
tonight thank you